together  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  if you've got somebody sitting beside  that first give an arrow person sitting  beside that person and all they see is a  symbol of murder rape  and theft it's not harmless fun and the  same way that I said someone wouldn't go  to an American football match draped in  a Confederate flag and sit beside an  African-American person and you know hey  how are you doing  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  if we look at it in a postcolonial  context many of the most damaging most  ugly most racist stereotypes of the Arab  world can be traced directly back to  this  encounter which occurred many hundreds  of years before colonial times  foreign  [Applause]